all right everybody welcome to the
google hangout i'm really excited to
have a friend of mine tour wrestling
here with me and tour is a time
management guru he's time management
chef you can check out more about him in
the description below he's been putting
together a series of mash up so he's
talking to a lot of successful
entrepreneurs and experts hitting their
views on different topics and he matches
it all together into a mega post but
then gets a lot of attention and
interest and so he asked me to join his
most recent one and I said hey let's
turn this into a google hangout instead
of just me answering by email and so
here we are for welcome aboard Thank You
Evan I'm honored to be here that's so
awesome so today you want to talk about
goal-setting so what tell us a little
about what you're doing with the mash up
and then how you want me to help you
yeah excellent I will so basically
basically what I've been doing I've been
reaching out to like a lot of
influencers like yourself Evan and I'm
answering and asking them the question
like what how today set goals in their
business what is the process because
people are really struggling with goal
setting and many people are like if you
say the word goal-setting they're like
starting to kind of looking at the
ceiling and and just starting to your
because like there's it's so boring
because people don't like to set goals
they want kind of results but then again
it's a long process so yeah so so access
it yourself before I get into my aunt's
from wal setting what are some of the
things that other people have said so my
audience can also learn from the experts
you've been talking to you and so far
there's been saying a lot about to have
like clarity and that you want you don't
want to your for instance one person
said that he it's important to have like
long-term goals and short-term goals so
you can have like more like long project
long girls like you will focusing on
three to five years but then again it's
very important to go for the small wins
the low-hanging fruits so you will be
able to kind of get yourself the steam
up so you will also have
weekly goals I like that I like that
okay what else anything else interesting
yeah they are talking a lot about the
SMART goal approach to have like the
realistic goal setting you break it down
to a so it's able to measure on that
it's yeah it's really realistic to
achieve it cool i ask you that want to
learn and also to make sure that what I
said would be different so that you had
the more variety to your results um the
one thing that I would say and I agree
with a lot of that you know you want you
want to be specific you want to you
wanna have a you know a timeline you
want to touch something that's
measurable you know I want to feel happy
about my life it's you know something
specific that you can reach um I'll give
you 2 i'll give you two and you can see
which one you want to use the first one
is around accountability and you're much
more likely to follow through on a goal
when you commit to somebody else to do
it whether it's going to the gym whether
it's making marketing calls whether it's
whatever it is you have two different
business get your website up if you tell
somebody else that you're going to do it
you're much more likely to actually do
it and so get in the habit of being
accountable to somebody besides yourself
because those entrepreneurs you know you
don't have anybody bossing you around
it's all you can decide what I'm going
to do at my time today right and and
what that means we tend to do the things
that we are comfortable doing and not
necessarily things that were
uncomfortable doing but what we need to
do to grow ourselves and grow our
business and so when you commit to
somebody else you're way way way more
likely to follow through so I find that
that is super helpful the other thing I
wanted to say is don't be afraid to
change your goals um and that's maybe a
little of a curveball compared to what
you're going to be getting I find that
quite often people will will set a goal
and then they'll start working towards
it and then they'll stop and one of the
big reasons is because they're no longer
passionate about that will they set for
themselves and that's that's that's okay
like that's normal that's human nature
you're not going to be the same person
always and
as you start something you may discover
well that's not actually what you want
to do and so as you learn more about
yourself and as you start working on it
you may need to change your goal and
don't be afraid to change your goal if
it's not something that you're excited
about anymore I see too many people who
especially look like corporate
environment people who graduate and then
they kind of always want to start a
business but they don't have the guts to
do it or they're telling them themselves
stories was I can't do and so they said
corporate goals for themselves and I
want to reach this and I want to you
know become vp and then CEO and you
stick on this path that that isn't
really what excites you and what
motivates you to keep going and so I
make sure that I do a gut check I would
do a gut check at least once a week on
your big goal the little girls are great
I mean you should be able to hope to
accomplish those within a week the big
goals odd look at once we can do a gut
check and see is this something that
still motivates me like do I look at
that won't say I'm I'm expired to get up
to the angle work towards doing that or
like I don't really feel like it you
know I'm not feeling that well anymore
um because if that's where you're at
then you have to switch your goal and do
something that you are more passionate
about just makes little sense but what
would you say to her you're the time
management chef well what's your number
one tip that may be a little different
than what most people are saying about
how to set goals I like to do a
combination like first you of course
have the SMART goal system that the goal
should be like a specific measurable
attainable and then it should be
realistic and time specific so it's very
realistic how exactly are going to
mushroom and do it to set and achieve a
goal the challenge would have a setting
SMART goals is that people most people
will not push yourself outside the
comfort zone in order to kind of pushed
himself to become the best that they can
be so for instance if you do you can do
maximum 20 push-ups you set your goal to
do 20 push-ups not very exciting right
because you've done it several times
before
so you will you will do it again so I've
kind of created another goal setting
system that is called dump go so not
smart but dump and it's like big hairy
girls and it's D success for dreaming
and users for uplifting and answers for
massive cojones so means Spanish for my
big balls and then you have be four
barely attainable I like it I like it so
basically what i do i have the SMART
goal and the dunkle and then i also
created a system it's actually our blog
post to publish today that the dump
smart system where I take a big hairy
goal and I break it down into smaller
pieces or each small piece is a SMART
goal so basically it would be like if
you said you wanted to earn I yeah
twelve-thousand dollars per year then
you break it down okay you have to earn
thousand dollars per month and then you
break it down further down to say okay
which five activities do I have to focus
on every single day in order to hit my
thousand dollars each month so you take
the big old break it down and then you
kind of go further into detest to that
specific activities each day I love it I
love it that's why you're the time
management Chapman the question coming
in my work rota who's saying how do you
structure and break down your goals do
you set goals daily weekly monthly
yearly yeah that was probably play for
you Evan or no one will both actually
you go first yeah okay thank you I have
a I go for yearly goals so I have a goal
to hit like X number of subscribers and
then I break it down to as I told you
before with Madame smart system to
monthly goals and then I hope you some
doing that into specific activities so
in my instance i'm up i'm a fairly new
blogger so my platform is flogging so
everything I do is about delivering
awesome content which is something I
also learned by you Evan and to get
exposed as much as possible so my goal
is to write to guest post every single
week in addition to a massive outreach
and just really delivering awesome
content so I have to kind of push my
pace all the time to do always do
specific activities that will get me
exposure but also deliver awesome well
you to the readers I love it for me I
have one I start with like a lifetime
goal so I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs so I don't know when
exactly that's gonna happen but I'm
worked words that every day and that's
maybe that's a dumb goal that's it
that's it that's my dreaming goal that
gets me excited every morning it's
dreaming it's uplifting a massive
cojones I know is it checked what was
low is the what was the last ones barely
attainable barely attainable well there
ya like it so that's my dummbell I just
feel like that keeps me excited and
motivated to keep going um I also like
having I hope I said daily goals I like
having um if you have one main goal that
I'm working on um and I said that as an
annual target so I'm only on YouTube
right now you guys can probably tell you
guys watching you know where to necto
asked me to interview say let's do it on
YouTube yeah I'm all in on YouTube and
my goal is I'm at an agency you have an
agent that represents for your books
being deals and all that and my goal was
to be the number one guy at the agency
uh and this month I'm gonna pass that
guy like probably tomorrow I'm going to
pass that guy yes I never ruin tomorrow
I'll be number one probably tomorrow
maybe the next day but it's happening
it's happening this month it's happening
for the innocent one that's really
awesome now I just you have to send me
an email when you do so it can take some
regulations picture so I something we're
gonna cross a hundred thousand
subscribers on the channel whoa only the
weekend or early next week depending on
how every day goes
that was my that's been my goal for a
while um and now I like I'm I what's is
the plumber like I hit it like hmm who
do I what do I do next like what's my
next target is what I find once you hit
a goal then then it can be a little
depressing then you like get all this
growth and then you start the plateau
because you don't have your next goal
and so I'm actually trying to find who's
the next person that I want to now go
after in terms of beating them on
YouTube just step around like that
head-to-head competition even though he
didn't know that was you didn't know
this I coming Oh what's he doing how's
his number I thought I got a bad Rosie
to do more um so now I got to find the
next person so on I'm open to
suggestions if you guys have suggestions
as the Sifl next channel that I shaped
kind of take on and try to eat in terms
of novel subscribers um that that's kind
of what I'm looking at next so yes I
have like my big huge goal and then I
always have one important goal that I'm
I try to look at it an annual basis um
but I mean I accomplished this one
before the end of the year it's now I'm
gonna have to up my game and then go for
the next one um Keith the same thinks
the dumb wolves idea i'll check this out
I you came up with this right toward um
is your thing or there's this from
somewhere else and probably somewhere I
think someone else has been talking
about it as well but there anyway i made
my definition so it's probably a little
bit different than the dump smart goal
system ii i have put it into like a
specific system with templates and free
course on how to crush your a ghost so
yeah i like to do something very
thorough when i do it so it will ya just
be a be great value to people i just
don't care cool so you can check that
out there's a linked it to Torres
website in the description you can go to
the site and check out that sucker um
next question Keith how many goals do
you set daily maximum how many goals per
day tour my goals each day and my number
one goal actually every day is too
I complete my most important tasks on my
to-do list whether I feel like it or not
so i used the 8020 rule identified the
most income generating activities and I
do them no matter what so if my
apartment was catching fire and the fire
department were here I I would finish my
main activities no matter what that
that's my most important goal each each
and every day up for me when I find that
goes really well hey me hey with goal
setting is setting a schedule for myself
so studying different days I do
different things so Thursday today's
Thursday is my public facing day so I
have three google hangouts today I have
two phone calls I have my meetings I
have my radio show that's what I do on
thursdays and wednesdays i do all my
filming on tuesdays i write my book I
mondays i do my business tasks and so my
goal lead today is basically making sure
that i get all of that stuff done
because if I know if I stick to the
schedule that I set for myself I'm going
to achieve my bigger goals and so the
challenge every day just making sure
that I stick to my schedule you know
it's great to find it out loud they got
do the work right the work is two men so
yeah I find like having a goal I think
then then creating a schedule that if
you do these steps you will accomplish
your goal and then your daily goal just
becomes I want to do what I said I was
going to do follow the plan yeah um tell
me wrote in to say I should go out for
addicted to success they have many subs
i'm looking at up a ticket to success TV
has 23,000 subs we're going to cross a
hundred soon so maybe that's I don't
that's the right channel or not but I'm
open to other ideas that people may have
um next mmm anagen hope i pronounced
that okay how to set long-term goals and
track them what do you think yeah how
you track them the nice thing about the
if you do it systematically you want to
set a goal it
I it doesn't care if it's a short-term
goal or a long-term goal you you want to
be able to track it no matter what I
think it was was it excuse me if I'm
saying wrong now but i think it was
Peter Drucker said if if it can't be
measured it can't be improved yeah I
think that's it yeah so you can't say
like this oh I want to be more
successful in 10 years and then you like
have a no measurement and no parameters
how are you going to measure that but so
for instance if you say I want to lose
weight in 2 months but it's it's it
needs to be more specific if you say I
want to lose 10 pounds the next two
months that's okay so you have to even
though it's a big ol you have to put a
number on it so you have to measure it
and you have to be able to keep the
progress and you have to have a deadline
I like it um I think in terms of how to
set the goal it should be something that
is motivating to you something that you
looking forward to doing you aspire to
it's dumb right it's a nap through um
something that you wake up and you look
I said yeah I want to do that is if it's
not it's not inspiring and what's the
point and then something that you have
an easy way to be able to track because
if you don't feel like you're making
progress you can quickly lose motivation
so for me as an example I want to be the
most successful YouTube channel for
entrepreneurs um the only person is
marie forleo actually you should lock to
marie forleo marie coming after you I
think she's like 180,000 or something um
it's easy for me to track that right i
can go in every day please excel file I
can see how many subscribers she had how
many do I have how many have we grown
like am i catching up or am i falling
creek behind um that was one of the
things that really motivated me when I
was looking at the guy who was in my
agency he was ahead of me to start with
and as I plotted our daily growth his
daily growth was ahead of mine too right
so it's like I'm not even catching up I
gotta go I gotta deliver better
value to you guys to get more
subscribers so at least I'm closed in a
gap because every month for getting
further and further away and that
motivated me to kind of kick it up a
notch and put more effort into it and
bring on a video aquifer and get a
second editor entire researcher to to
add more volume for you guys in the
channel so something that is big and
motivating to you and then something
that you can easily track on a regular
basis to see if you're making progress
yeah varun rights in what to do when you
can't find your purpose in spite of
trying your hands on a lot of things
what do you think oh the we do what we
jazzed up yeah you ain't to first you
went to first go Owens and when it comes
to you need to follow your questions so
it can really heart is fine or options
advanced so when I was three years old I
was working as a in one of biggest and
martial arts equipment and supplies food
really like cotton gloves and Judah past
effort to bolster their home of no way
oh and that was Michael at that time oh
you're really cutting out I don't know
what I'm happy you can see me Your Honor
I have a I have some poor connection
here because she look it up Molly's yeah
kind of fix your connection and I'll
turn I'll answer that let me know when
you're back on yet um should I just need
to call and come back door yeah you can
try that you can leave and come back
i'll just keep riffling i'll keep
talking with you guys um yeah UK if you
don't know what your purpose is then you
have to keep exploring like just keep
trying just try more stuff um when I
went to start salsa dancing um I you
know on paper it looks like a stupid
decision I'm too tall you know I don't
speak the language I don't understand
the music it's just wouldn't make sense
is a business opportunity but I went and
I fell in love with it
and I tried a whole bunch of dif England
said yes to a lot of stuff how I became
interested on her ship was I said yes to
doing an interview or doing a speech
sorry the YMCA to help their young
entrepreneurs and so that just saying
yeah it's just getting involved and and
being willing to move away for something
because you're not interested in it keep
going till you find a thing that makes
you come alive and don't put so much
pressure on yourself right if I went to
that first salsa class and said this has
to be my passion if I'm not interested
in it I can't turn a business in it then
I'm going to leave it then I probably
would have left it because I put too
much pressure myself we want to just go
and have fun and see what makes you come
alive and if you do that then the next
you'll go back the next day is even
makes you come a little more a lot and
just keep at it and you'll eventually
find the thing that you are meant to do
I'm just a wholehearted believer in
exploring until you find thing that
makes you super excited more questions
okay how do you motivate yourself again
if you don't achieve the goals you set
motivation is hard and I think I think
the easiest thing that helps me is
having the morning routine uh why I find
as a lot of people will have you may
listen to this you what time is it now
it's 220 here in Toronto maybe listen to
this now maybe you get excited you go do
something but like what happened to your
whole morning right you don't want to
leave with the chance that you listened
to it a tape or watch a video read a
book or seeing a magazine article that
that gets you excited that makes you
come alive you want to plan that in
right the reason why i create the the
end Express on the environment series on
this channel is to help motivate you
guys to stay on track to believe in your
goals and believe in yourself so if
you're not seeing results right you're
not you're trying to over and over and
over and over and over and over again I
would try to just remind myself of what
am I trying to do why's it so important
what's the big picture that I'm going
after and then try to break it down into
things that you can measure and can get
some success woods right so I can look
at my subscribers and see those going up
maybe it's not going up as fast as I
want or maybe I'm losing track ground
compared to somebody else and so that
forces me to want to do better right but
I start my day
every deal with that morning routine I
do a bunch of things and I can go more
if you guys want but I do a bunch of
things that get me excited to get me
motivated that make me want to go and
like kill the day right and you need to
do that on purpose every morning because
for me I give you super motivated and
excited one day because something
happens and then I go to sleep and I
wake up the next day and I feel like I'm
starting over from scratch i
don't--that's you some people I guess
can live off of one thing for weeks and
months at a time but for me I needed
daily I need something every morning you
get me kick-started and ready to go I'm
sorry highly encourage you guys to do
that too uh do you write down your goals
is my work roda do you write down your
goals on paper computer or mobile uh I
usually write them down on my computer
um I usually have an excel file where I
write things down and then track and
I'll also use Evernote to kind of save
things um I find that when I'm a lot of
times my ideas come from when I'm not in
front of my computer when I'm off
traveling when I play with my son when
I'm a dinner when I'm dancing and as
soon as I get that idea what I try to do
is email myself and so I have a kind of
written record of it and then I'll go
home and whatever the next day or later
that evening i'll update my evernote
file or update my excel chart um and so
I have a huge excel file that I track a
whole bunch of different things I talk
about my main goal being my YouTube
subscribers right now but i'll try a
bunch of different stuff from my
newsletter subscribers to my website
traffic to my social media interactions
a whole bunch of different things that I
tracked every month and I find that that
just helps keep me keep me on track the
danger though the danger is being too
OCD about it I'm borderline sometimes
like I'll usually check because I'm so
close to hitting my target now I'm
checking every day sometimes multiple
times a day and that's that's that's
dangerous right you could give this
friend so much i'm just checking in and
updates and stats that you don't
actually do anything so you have to make
sure that you are actually taking action
on your goals and not just not just
watching
next aryan dumb goals haha awesome what
about too many goals if you don't want
to go in one direction because you have
too many interests yeah that's a huge
issue for a lot of entrepreneurs and
myself included we all have these files
of ideas and things that we want to work
on but but you know can't because you
don't have enough time and you have to
just focus and prioritize like I look at
my list i think i think what can i add
the most value to my business today what
can i do to add the most value and what
I'm most excited by and sometimes you
get excited by one thing and in that
passion fades don't be afraid to give
that up to go for something else because
you're more excited my business is
always a reflection of Who I am and what
I'm interested in the the videos on my
channel have always had reflected that i
made in stress 0 in the top 10 list
selfishly for me and i'm super honored
and glad and excited that you guys get
value from them as well but i felt like
i needed them for me in my business to
continue to learn from the greats in
entrepreneurship and so if i ever stop
being a you sure than that then i'll
stop making the videos and i'll move on
to something else something else that
I'm more passionate and excited by maybe
one last question because I got to get
on a call in four minutes so quickly I
always want to accomplish my goals and
perfection but this consumes a lot of my
time this is good or bad from venkatesan
elbow pronounce that okay ah
perfectionism is a huge issue for a lot
of entrepreneurs myself included and
what really helped me kind of get over
trying to make the perfect thing all the
time is understanding that it's a
process you know I want to make every
video as good as I can as an example but
then I know that it's not going to be
perfect that I'm going to make mistakes
and when we find a mistake or we find
something we want to improve even look
at you look at the thumbnails as a minor
you do the thumbnails on our Channel
they all have a little airplane now
you'll have a second icon I'm not going
back to my old videos and adding those
in right this is everything we do is
from now on and we can move the no idea
we're doing it from now on and i find
that helps me actually
get stuff out because before that I'd
always focus on it has to be perfect
they need to be perfect I have one more
idea I've got one more idea and do one
more thing we could do this extra thing
to make it great and then you never get
anything out right and so understanding
that when you launch something it's not
going to be perfect and it will never be
perfect you're just stretching
consistently to try to make it better
and better and better and better I
learned that lesson the hard way because
in my first company we tried to make
things perfect and ended up losing a 40
million dollar deal because of it and
you know I didn't know any better at the
time I was 22 um but then that hurts
right come on that hurts and so I I
fight against my perfectionist nature by
understanding as a process that was
always just going to get better and
better and better every time we launched
something new every new video every new
blog post every new newsletter every you
google hangout you know we try to make
it better each time and I find that
helps so thank you guys so much for
watching I knows a bunch more questions
I didn't get to I don't know what
happened the tour isn't your connection
died but that's okay you can check his
info up in the description below I have
to hop on a call i apprec-- you guys
love you so much I will see you soon
continue to believe